bonsoir
salut dun cette fille va faire la
fortune de toute sa famille
elle aura une ligne de vêtement une
[Musique]
fondation tu as été génial aujourd'hui
merci ça ressemble plus à du tennis à ce
niveau c'est carrément un autre
[Applaudissements]
sport passé nous voir tout à l'heure tu
veux que je vienne vous border non pour
continuer à
[Musique]
discuter ça vous arrive souvent de
draguer la même fille non pas si souvent
que ça on a des goûts différents
d'habitude tu veux dire que je devrais
être flatté mais toi tu plais à tous les
garçons non allezit mais lequel de nous
[Musique]
de
il est pas amoureux de toi qu'est-ce qui
te fait dire que j'ai envie qu'on soit
amoureux de moi ça fait plaisir de te
voir t'enflammer comme ça même si c'est
pour ma
copine son coach Donalson qui est
également sa femme je joue pour ns deux
t peut-être que ce qui te dérange c'est
qu'elle a pu être attiré par un type
comme moiand était adolescent quand on
était adolescent attends je
t'aime je
[Musique]
sais le tennis tu sais pas ce que
c'est c'est une histoire à
deux on a partagé un truc très beau
ensemble on y
croit j'en prends bien soin de mes deux
petits
blancs tu avais tout prévu j'imagine non
pas
[Musique]
ça